otro día de salvas sobre la frontera sur
de líbano esta vez fue el ejército
israelí el que disparó por tercer día
consecutivo después de que el viernes el
grupo chiíta hezbollah respaldado por
irán lanzar una ráfaga de cohetes desde
el líbano para algunos residentes de la
frontera los enfrentamientos son un
doloroso recordatorio de los conflictos
de 2006 una nota de los que vivimos en
estos pueblos fronterizos siempre
estamos sometidos a este tipo de acoso
por parte del enemigo que empuja a la
gente a huir de sus aldeas ahora los
ataques aéreos israelíes contra
territorio libanés son los primeros
desde 2014 cuando los aviones de guerra
atacaron el territorio cerca de la
frontera con siria
naciones unidas- hizo un llamado a la
calma
parís pedimos a todas las partes que
actúen con la máxima moderación y
mantengan la estabilidad líbano no puede
permitirse otra crisis es esencial que
todos los actores implicados eviten
cualquier acción que pueda exacerbar
ascensiones y conducir a errores de
cálculo por el momento los años siguen
siendo mínimos y no hay víctimas
mortales puesto que los disparos siempre
han caído sobre solares vacíos
interceptados a tiempo el incremento de
las tensiones provocó una ola de
críticas contra hezbollah en líbano un
país devastado por las múltiples crisis
políticas económicas y sociales que se
han agravado en los últimos años